now you used to see a lot of scientific
council within government it was a
common thing during most of my lifespan
Offices of Technology Assessment and so
forth a lot of these guys cluttering up
the scene in government they are a dying
breed because fundamentalists and
oligarchs both despise science they
don't want to anything to have they
won't have anything to do with them now
in this ancient standard of futurism the
gold standard is Vannevar Bush from the
1940s who was one of the inventors of
the atomic bomb a master engineer of the
Manhattan Project it was also the father
of the American National Science
Foundation because he wrote the
extremely important futurist text
science the endless frontier that screed
is probably the greatest work of
futurism ever put onto paper with a
typewriter it's really an impressive
governmental document and you know and
aimed at the head of state so there's
still a problem with this it's like why
isn't science as respected as it was and
I think the problem there is cultural
and because Americans and especially
Californians have a severe moral problem
with the idea that frontiers and that
they're not endless in fact that gold
rush is just get old and die ugly
they're not always young and pretty and
beautiful and glamorous and
forward-looking they get old and cranky
and weird you know and I like obsessed
with themselves and it kind of like
moved from you know what it was right
from savagery to barbarism without
civilization ever occurring savagery
barbarism the decadence without without
a civilization is a typical frontier
development so you know to think that
the science is an endless frontier is
actually a bad paradigm especially for a
futurist or a scientist for instance
paleontology is an important science
which is about things that ended a long
time ago and they just ended they're not
gone they're not gonna revive you're not
gonna improve the trilobite s-- right
just but it's important to understand
what's going on in geologic time whether
there's anything to do with it or not
and there are also many areas
scientific investigation that are not
endless frontiers are dead ends I mean
they're called the sacks they have to be
abandoned such as phlogiston you know or
the luminiferous ether or spontaneous
generation or even some aspects of
Newtonian physics I mean they just
they're not up to speed and you know you
have to let those go scientific truth is
provisional it's not permanent and
eternal and science as a human
Enterprise I mean the actual business of
science and I how scientists are
recruited promoted how they quote one
another that's a very time bound very
social kind of situation the change is
quite a lot as time as time goes on so
if you think that atomic physics or
maybe the truth of atomic physics the
scientific truth of atomic physics is
somehow an eternal thing then you have
to go all-out for nuclear power or giant
gadgets like these superconducting
supercollider which is unwise I mean
that ambition is going to end in tears
if you ask the government for 11 billion
dollars for a superb scientific
instrument that is not going to work
it's just you can't it can't be built
that is bad politics it's poor
statesmanship you're a scientific
futurist but you gave bad advice so if
you're a scientific futurist and you're
in the government pace layer you can't
simply say to them I have some
Inconvenient Truth here look at this
math it won't work you have to say I
have some Inconvenient Truth here and I
can use it to win world war two with a
secret super weapon that was the van Eva
Bush method and that's that's what life
is like and the government pay slayer
when things are really cracking right
along
[Music]